today i will be donating 50 000
to small twitch streamers this is gonna
be fun he currently has one viewer which
means if we weren't watching he'd have
zero oof he is streaming to nobody which
means he gets money yes time to give him
money uh does he even have a donation
link do you have a donation link oh
andy's the imposter carl we are going to
give this guy 10 grand but he doesn't
have a donation link
that's why you should have a donation
link idk how to set it up all right next
person
let's see if he has a donation button
because lots of people this size don't
oh
he has a donation button and it looks
like a waffle look at that that's
actually kind of creative that makes me
want to give him money it does mr beast
gaming that's that's new we're going to
start off with a big one 9
999.99 and 99 cents
we're about to give this random small
streamer 10 000 what does it say joe say
no more imagine getting ten thousand
dollars and they just say joe all right
here we go the world's most expensive yo
mama joke
all right we did it we did it it's about
to happen and i have some awesome
viewers right now oh wait it popped up
in the chat mr beast gaming just tipped
999 he doesn't even have an overlay
streaming a rerun wait
oh he's not even live right now this is
a rerun basically that means he streamed
this morning and it's replaying the
stream he's not actually live he's gonna
open his paypal account and just have 10
grand and be like why is there 10 grand
here congrats baldwaffle at 10 grand
that was an expensive screw-up all right
chris can we screw up any worse um let's
see on the next one we have our next
victim here can you confirm it's not a
rerun it is not a re-run he is actually
there and present if i waste another 10
grand i'm gonna cry ten thousand dollars
in the queue
yeah we need to see what he says to joe
okay joe
oh it popped up
terribly wait what
wait that is that actually mr beast it
is hey hey how's it going that is a lot
of money man do you want me to do
anything for that money
you don't have to do anything congrats
on being
rich what a sweet kid this is absolutely
mad all you gotta do is stream to zero
people we'll just give you ten grand
people are gonna have people popping in
their chat they're like no get out get
out mr beastman
subscribe to mr peace gaming because
he's an absolute mention hit the
subscribe button confession time what's
up this person has five viewers you
subtract us that's four viewers it's not
zero viewers um it's still small though
oh yeah let's make sure okay it's not a
re-run we're gonna start small work our
way up four four thousand four thousand
feels right yeah you're
on youtube
we have noticed suspicious activity on
your paypal account what's suspicious
about giving four thousand dollars to
minecraft streamers good okay paypal
approved it we're good we're not locked
out of our account yet bro look at his
face
whoa
why that can't be real i followed you on
twitter to prove it's real i legit just
followed him on twitter so he knows i'm
real you're gonna see his face light up
look at that he saw it bro
he lost the viewer so it's like oh you
got a 4 000 donation i'm out my heart is
beating up really fast right now i'm
currently
sitting on my bed as my chair i'm going
to buy a chair to sit on it's going to
be a nice chair he can afford a chair
now you're going to help his back
support which will probably save him
from spinal surgery which will save him
even more money dude this was like a 400
000 donation title now
is this the best day of your life it's
definitely up there top five top five
best days of his life jeez what happened
to him he's like oh yeah i won the
lottery it's time as i like to say it
for our next victim victim of receiving
money all right let's see what his top
donation ever is fifty dollars okay i'm
just gonna press random keys
three three four two sure here we go
wait we should meow with them meow yeah
there we go all right time for another
episode of will paypal lock my account
oh they didn't well that was a great
episode of well paypal lock my account
there it is bottom left oh
nb gaming that's a lot
it's exactly 60 times bigger than your
biggest donation holy cow he's
processing it
he's looking you could tell he's
checking his monitor make sure oh mr
beast what up hey how's it going welcome
welcome he's getting it now he's getting
it
my man just left peter my man gets three
grand and leaves his chair is green but
since he has a green screen it should be
keyed out but it's not no or maybe he's
just on a different planet
here we go
we got the signed shirt he goes oh he
has a signed shirt santa morrison what
did the shirt cost like 25 bucks or
something okay 2 500. you know paypal's
just screaming right now
forty eight hundred ninety two dollars
just now i'm at a loss of words right
now what an innocent soul and keep up
the good work man yeah awesome i hope
you have a wonderful day thank you
youtube next
you're supposed to say streamer oh hey
cut that part streamer
chris what is this this is a ginseng
streamer chris literally 10 hours a day
plays ginseng impacts the only game that
matters
since it means a lot to chris we'll do
five hundred
psych five thousand hey
the five thousand is about to go through
what
why oh jesus christ why not thank you so
much but
why you don't even know who i am or what
i do or you're right i literally know
nothing about you as of three minutes
ago i didn't know you existed this
character's been waiting to say
something for so long i can't even think
of words right now please everyone
subscribe to mr beastgaming you heard it
here click that subscribe button next
streamer ninja's live ninja what's the
thumbnail for this video look at the
views does ninja equal views it might i
need to get fortnite again you can play
as an anime girl though it won't let us
donate to ninja paypal's like listen
he's gotten enough all right he's
playing with kurt is on youtube
mvgaming6000
is that actually mr beast
thousand dollars
would it be a twitch donation video
without ninja but i couldn't get ninja's
donation to work so i'm doing you
because you are playing with him
2 000. that's enough money for me to eat
food for a week chat
this is why we always come back to him
he has great energy three thousand
dollars to say hi to ninja yeah i'm just
wondering what he thought of the
pictures i sent last night he never
responded oh what's going on if i have
to donate to courage to tell ninja this
seems to be the most efficient way i did
it
he said what pictures dude who got my
freaking pictures then those are
personal
not anymore you guys should i do like a
dance or something jimmy do you need me
to do more oh he said he could do a
dance for us so um
yeah let's move on
yeah
let's let him think about that with his
chat is she just food shopping yes irl
stream she's talking about danishes over
there right i think in english is just
called danish but i don't know i want to
make sure her alerts are actually on so
we're only going to donate
two thousand dollars that's it yes oh
okay she's at a random supermarket in
russia she's showing us around it says
it in chat it's probably gonna show up
will she acknowledge it
no that's not mr beast right
that cannot be excused
she's freaking out i thought you're
right it is she's freaking out in the
middle of the freaking grocery store
she's literally crying in a grocery
store but that's so legit though no that
cannot be the real mystery beast are we
the real mr beast
yes she freaked out about two thousand
dollars yes yes so five thousand buy
that danish all right let's see let's
make her cry
oh it popped up on screen look at the
chat they're freaking out dude
viewership is spiking people are losing
their minds in chat look at him
she's like skipping through
she's so happy i'm gonna build
educational games now she's a game
designer that's why i started streaming
i wanted to try to educate people oh
okay let's go buy the danish finally
what we've been waiting for that's it
right there that's our danish that's
ordained thank you so much no problem
we're gonna head to the next streamer
the bald waffle just said hey did you
donate to the channel recently the guy
we gave 10 grand that was
back telling bald waffle that his 10k is
real just pull up my paypal account i
only have 846.68
left
oh no all right so which means uh this
is our last streamer i'm just going to
copy the remaining balance in my paypal
and paste it here so i should have zero
dollars happy birthday she's gonna
refund it's not my birthday
oh it went through went through it went
through one through
boom
she needs to see it we wish you happy
birthday how is she gonna have a happy
birthday if she doesn't see it jimmy she
would have just saw it wait
she saw it
um wait one second guys she ended her
stream no no it's probably it has to
just be loud it has to just be lagged
now she's unbroke but broke she just
retired she's like all right that's all
i'm gone finally
uh i know it's not your birthday but if
it is then happy birthday
we got a giggle this is really a lot of
money a lot of money
and thank you so much maybe if we gave
her 10 grand oh my god instead of the
bald waffle that was afk this this is
all i got out of the bald waffle hey did
you donate to the channel recently
mb gaming you don't know me like in
general why can't you give me a lot of
money and thank you so much no problem
and thank you guys for watching if
you're not already hit that subscribe
button right now i want 20 million
subscribers because it would look cool